hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts high-throughput
screening robotics within the UK Centre
for drug discovery is ni by Marc
wiglesworth director high-throughput
screening AstraZeneca I am Kelly ba code
lab routes and I will be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type your questions and hit
set well answer as many questions as we
need time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or used to ask the
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming mark
wiglesworth I'll now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You
Kaylee and thank you lab roots for the
invitation to come in speak today I am
going to talk to you about the high
throughput screening infrastructure the
collaborations that we've put together
to support that infrastructure and the
innovations that we've made along the
way through those collaborations and at
the very end of the presentation I'll
also take you through reliability why
that's important to us and how we're
going to in support this screening
infrastructure forward so the UK sense
of belief discovery is Center created by
Astra Zeneca
it's been created at least in part
because of an opportunity to move our
research and development facility
in the UK and facility classically was
near Manchester per Astra Zeneca and
this will relocate to a new building
near Cambridge and with that we've had
an opportunity to look at the entire
supporting infrastructure across
compound management and screening and
really redesign that in the best
possible way and as we've been doing
that we've also been thinking about the
ways in which we can work and the UK
Center is really about develop
developing a new approaches to how to
put screening new approaches of finding
molecules that ultimately will help
patients and we're doing this by
collaborating with groups like the
Medical Research Council and Cancer
Research UK and what will be happening
in this new building is that their
people will be working alongside
AstraZeneca steeple running their own
projects and they'll be free to take
their projects outside of the building
and continue to work on them within
their own infrastructure and the only
thing that we ask in return is that if
there's something that there's become
potentially a medicine that they come
back to us and we have a first right to
to offer them a market rate on on their
discovery so really quite a different
way of working and and quite a different
way of running the science within the
facility and this isn't the only way in
which we're changing the only way in
which we're looking to drive new
collaborations and this slide shows just
a few of the collaborations that we've
put in place in Astra Zeneca
over the last few years more than a
hundred covering many different areas
but but it represents a really real
drive to embrace what's outside of Astra
Zeneca to work with other companies and
create shared value
and our open innovation website also
reflects this on this website you can go
on and gain access to our clinic
clinical compound collection perhaps for
repurposing you can nominate a new
chemistry that you might have within
your establishment to come into our
screening collection and you can
actually nominate projects as well
targets that you want to bring either to
screen with us in in the UK Center and
all targets for which you you would like
to access diversity collections to
screen externally and and these external
collaborations are a an important part
of our open innovation offering and
slide here shows gives you some feeling
for how this is distributed across the
globe and and we now have over 79
projects in this portfolio where we
shared compounds or people to advance
their own projects and the input from
AstraZeneca isn't just about sending in
those compounds it's also about and
guidance on acid development screening
Cascades workup on computing
computational chemistry and data
analysis so that the right compounds can
be found and hopefully that will lead to
a successful project completion and if
we turn our attention back to the UK
Center and here we're screening those
collaborative projects if we go back to
2014 we we haven't learned an open
innovation screen of this type at all
only in recent years have we started to
see a growth in in this portfolio with
actually a projected growth out to 2020
of 20 screens within this portfolio it's
really quite an astonishing rate of
growth
though over five years and this has been
driven there's been the thinner a lot of
all work to this of course it's been
driven by the open innovation portfolio
that I shared or the website that I
shared a few slides ago and the global
academic community being able to propose
projects into this portfolio but also
those strategic collaborations I talked
about with the Medical Research Council
and Cancer Research UK and all of these
came online through 2015-16 we're now
also seeing an opportunity to work with
other groups in in a different way and
we've recently announced a collaboration
with Charles River
now here Charles River will be able to
bring their own customers projects into
the UK Center and they'll be able to
screen and their customers projects on
our infrastructure in a shared cost
model again bringing benefit to both
organizations in the infrastructure that
we will have created so it's a it's a
really strong portfolio and a great
opportunity for all of these academic
groups and other organizations to access
and the next slide here on slide aid is
a photograph of one of the robotic
systems and but will also be able to
move to a video of this facility and
just in a moment we'll play you a video
so you can see really what what is on
offer until we play that video
AstraZeneca are entering a new era in
drug discovery by unveiling the world's
most advanced drug discovery robot we
decided to take the very best of all our
learning from the past two decades and
say if we had a blank sheet of paper how
would we do this rather than have to
change the science says it would fit
with the robot it was really important
for us with these new robots that they
should work for the science niccola bees
up to three times faster than our
previous robots and can test millions of
potential compounds against the
disease's we're trying to address
acoustic delivery technology when
combined with Nicola Bay will allow us
to work in a way which is not only more
efficient but more sophisticated
unlike other robots Nicola bee can work
safely next to our scientists and even
be controlled remotely via a tablet this
gives us a better chance than ever of
finding suitable compounds which can
progress into potential life-changing
medicines of the future Astra Zeneca
open innovation program is transforming
the model through which industry is
working with academia by getting
research partners access to our
laboratories our compound library and to
our robots it's very exciting the Astra
Zeneca are opening their doors and
letting scientists from academic
organizations into their labs it will
have a real positive impact on our work
something which would previously have
taken a year to do and now we'll be able
to do your in a few months
partnerships allow us to work with real
world leaders in specific areas sharing
scientific knowledge process knowledge
and technical knowledge for the benefit
of all parties this will enable us to
push the boundaries of science and
deliver more life-changing medicines
than ever before
okay brilliant I hope the video gives
you a sense of the types of robotics the
scale and the way that we're working in
that facility and I'm also going to go
on in and tell you an awful lot more
about what we've got here
and there's this slide gives you a sense
of how many different groups we've had
to work with to to create this
infrastructure I'm going to tell you
first and foremost about collaboration
with high res for our aberrations with
some of the other groups that are on
this slide and you may also have seen
presentations on other collaborations
between lamp sight and waters to create
an acoustic miss mass spectrometry
platform for screening all between lab
site and Brooks in creation of an
acoustic tube project for compound
management again here to accelerate
project management so a compound
management workflows and the efficiency
of of storage and dispense and I'm not
going to go through the details of those
today with us as I've already said it
there you do up online you may well be
able to find those as well they do form
Park the UK census infrastructure so
first on the collaboration with high res
and here we wanted to build a different
type of screening automation we have
experience of working with high res and
with Agilent by ourselves over recent
years and we liked the way that these
fully automated systems were able to
build some quite complex assay systems
but all of these screening robotics are
enclosed and it really limited how we
could use the equipment within them and
historically and fully automated systems
were perhaps a little bit more open but
and
we're more limited in their construction
and what they could deliver and whereas
we liked the flexibility needs abuse of
these small robotic systems on the
bottom of the slide you know the modular
dispense systems they they dome offers
offer the complexity of screen that we
need with height we put screening and so
we decided to work with an high-res bias
solutions and we decided to work with
them because we liked their mobile cart
system and their micro dock system which
for us we felt provided a leading
automation platform for how to put
screening but we didn't really like the
way once the cart was undocked it was
difficult to use or or actually if it
was a dot onto a system sometimes it was
it was difficult to access and you could
improve the throughput if your reader
happen to have a stacker on it and but
quite often we put equipment onto these
systems and then not be able to use them
for other things and so that quickly
moved us to the concept of a mobile cart
that had its own robotics and the design
on this slide shows the precise robot
arm on a cart system and here even when
undocked were able to move plates round
from stackers to what is on hill the
dispensed carts and make additions of
different types from different
dispensers and it gave us a high-density
platform where we could put lots of
different dispensers or leaders or other
things onto and this was important again
for our transition into a new building
with limited space and and it also
created a common automation capability
and were able to iterate on these cart
systems we'll show you that in a slider
to stein if you take a closer look at
what we've done on these carts you can
see and you might have
in the video as well that these are
really open the photograph on the left
hand side shows access to the dispensers
as well as the robot arm to the bottom
line and the stacking system in the
middle there's a centrifuge underneath
that stacking system as well all of this
equipment is accessible it's easily
accessible to the user and just one
serve and do a manual equality control
and it's easily accessible if you just
wanted to come up to this system to run
one or two place rather than running get
on there fully automated some of the
things that we've done with these carts
to improve their functionality as well
with the dispensers is introduce
multi-port bowels these permit us to
earn our agents through the dispensers
and then switch to cleaning reagents
unattended and this will be programmed
and we have gravity drains from these
dispensers that plug into the into the
floor allowing us to take our waste away
fish efficiently on the bottom right we
can see dogs that sit over the equipment
this allows allows us to connect to air
vents to remove any potentially noxious
gases and make additions for key cell
reagents or reagents cancel a site such
as formaldehyde if we look more broadly
at the types of carts that we have in in
our laboratories today and we have
everything from the dispensed cart that
we've had a closer look at and through
two acoustic transfer carts shown again
in the middle of the slide a contact the
patter today it's a bee prep that will
soon become high Reza's prime system as
well as our reader systems we we have
our BMG fsx
multimode reader as our main workhorse
within the high throughput screening
and laboratory but we also have
complicated reader systems or cell
imaging the cell insights shown there
bottom-right transcriptomics capability
and the introduction of label 3
technologies like the corning epic and
all of this enable us to build quite a
complex portfolio of different assays
and once we got this cart system up and
running we're able then to and connect
cart systems to each other and you can
connect for example a dispense car with
your multimode reader and build very
simple biochemical assays we can
introduce like on ik cart systems for
storage of plates where we might
dispense store a cell plate or moving it
onto our salarjung system and there we
can start to bring in more complicated
SI systems but we can't run everything
through these cart systems we have to
also have more complicated robotic
systems and here we have to start to
look at evolve in the micro star
platform that high res had and we
focused on the carts as I've described
but then how to bring them together to
fully automate them and be able to pass
parts between all of those different and
pass plates sorry between all of those
different flavors of cars and we decided
to do this using the cooker and it's a
collaborative robots on the center of
this automation platform and and it's
collaborative ability means that it can
sense the environment around it it can
sense pressures if there was a user in
the environment and BOTS feedback so
unlike the historic robots that you
might have seen on the television in
automation factories and these robots
can be used safely next to our
scientists
and and providing they're not run across
speed okay so we have to bridge a gap
between wanting to run these robots at
full speed I'm wanting to learn them in
their maximum sensitivity mode and what
we were able to do there is introduced a
laser scanning technology to that
central robot platform and you can see
our zones in red orange and green and
that our sensor zones from these lasers
if somebody enters those regions it
begins to slow down or if it appears in
the red dirt zone it can have an
automatic stop guaranteeing safety of
our of our scientists and even if then
we remove carts you can see on the far
right and that zone automatically fills
in so that the carts can be taken away
and used for the purposes while this
robot system can can continue to operate
and really with with these alterations
and and the design of the micro start
together with the cart systems we had
quite a flexible portfolio of hardware
and being able to learn fully automated
individual cards or combination of cars
well we still felt that there was some
way to go in terms of the user
interaction with these and the the
ability to program and use these we
liked the simplicity and user interface
that we've seen historically with some
of the more simple automation systems
and the harriet's up there and
scheduling software salario and again we
worked in quite a detailed way with high
res to start to design salario in a
slightly different way so that it became
more simple for users to interact with
and first was alterations to version 3.2
where high res introduced a scripting
language for salario and it's this
starts to allow the program to make
decisions about a critical behavior and
starts to allow us to bring scripting
into I can I specific tasks so that they
can be grouped and and means that users
can use the software without needing to
understand how to code and script the
detailed scripting language
we'd also change the software so that it
can handle lids and plates is separate
resources permitting them to be
separated well and on the robot system
Edition to be made to the plate for
example and then the live return to it
and the software can track all of those
movements improving the workflows we've
introduced plate processing flow gates
so plates can be told to be held in
certain areas if there's an issue with
with processing upstream or downstream
of of that point and we've also
introduced with this version the ability
to run ever recover it will recovery
straight scripts and instead of having
to restart the protocols completely or
run the risk of losing your room or the
entirety of you learn you can learn
these recovery processes and skipping
awaits wanted plates out of your
protocol and allowing the robot system
to continue and in the next version of
salario here were anticipating some
further simplification of protocol
design to allow multiple threats and to
be defined again that simplifies the way
that the user can interact with them
they're going to be able to be
compressed and grouped into cartridges
again these cartridges can be easily
copied and pasted controls simplifying
that programming for use
abling the two strengths as a super user
an engineer or somebody who's just
wanted to learn their protocol on a
daily basis the software is now smart it
like a smart motorway it's able to
control the flow of plates around the
system and they can be stored for a few
seconds if they need to be in order to
let the traffic move out of the way
before moving on to a specific dispense
or reader and protocols and system
equipment resources can be used
differently with filters as well so if
there's a problem with a specific reader
or dispenser again you can easily filter
that within the software and find out
what problem is what does this mean for
us what do these changes mean for as
well in a scenario three point to the
use of the scripting language enables us
to automate the QC of our dispensers and
in this case it's the service and now
phase one of this and we can do this now
is that we can run an automatic QC of
the surface barrels using gravimetric
tests and collect that data that data
can then be manually uploaded into the
surface software to make the relevant
adjustments as we move forwards that
data will be automatically imported into
the it set of software so that a user
doesn't have to make that adjustment and
the plans longer-term is that and this
will be able to then be done within a
run the monitor performance and those
two adjustments will be able to be made
automatically and flagging plates or
parts of learners that have issues so
that they can be removed in the next
version of our software salario 3.3 and
the interconnection of the robot system
with gene data which is our database for
analyzing our screening data and this
will allow us to run our mycological QC
through a run and have that
automatically analyzed
additionally we'll be able to do things
like when imaging place with a quick
pass image pick out wells that are of
interest and go back into a full image
analysis giving us the high quality
images that we need and the three-putt
that's associated with high throughput
screening and next I'm going to go back
to some of the collaborations that we've
had in place outside of these large
pieces of infrastructure and I want to
talk to you about the collaboration with
Geiger in Switzerland on their surface
device and if we go back to 2015 Astra
Zeneca ran a an evaluation of a number
of different dispensers and at the time
the the surface was selected as a
dispenser the best fitted our needs
across and the asset development of
screening groups within our central
service organization and it's a
dispenser the very capably dispensers a
wide range of volumes from 15 an elite
set to 5 mils you can do that in three
eight four and 1536 well plates very
capable blade and it uses a micro valve
technology to enable this however for
high throughput screening there were
still some limitations on the throughput
of this device and so we've worked with
Geiger to implement some changes that
have really helped us and so he's a
really simple changes and I explain them
as we as we move through and but they
can make quite big differences to what
you can achieve within a high-throughput
screening environment and the first one
is the creation of an angled dispense
head for this device if you look at the
photograph of the wells in the top
middle of slide you can see in Penryn on
the place this is the different angles
that were trialed and at the bottom of
that image we've got 0
if you look across the two rows of wells
and dispensers that have been made you
can quite clearly see lots of air
bubbles within those wells those air
bubbles and if left as they are and can
really affect the quality of your assay
so the table underneath that image row
five and six the red text shows the CV
for a biochemical assay where we've not
centrifuge and clearly that CV is not
acceptable for the quality that we need
to reach within a screen organization so
you have to spin these plates
that's row seven and eight on that table
to reach an acceptable CV and quality
but that takes time
okay so what we've done by introducing
the angled head and you can see this and
in the photograph where we started by
introducing the angle head room the air
bubbles and again on the table we can
see that in rows 1 to 2 without
centrifugation
we still reaches an acceptable CV and as
we would if we span those plates and but
this time we're doing it with quite a
significant time-saving the other added
benefit for this system is that instead
of dispensing reagent directly into the
well if you're winning a cell assay
where that can display cells and affect
the quality and here you can dispense
down the side of the well and and we're
in a lower list of dislodging those
cells again delivering a higher quality
to the the screening assays in addition
to this and when we first started using
the syrtis system it's actually quite
difficult and to use and multiple valves
across the dispenser and had a four
valve dispensed had and we've worked
with and Geiger
to fully understand how we balance these
how we calibrate them and there's some
improvements in their software knowledge
which greatly improved that on the
left-hand side the top plate there shows
the types of issues that you see if this
isn't done properly the top needs 8 rows
dispensed with and one valve and clearly
that valve is very different to the rest
of the valves on on the plate which
which causes then an issue with the data
quality if you balance that you can
reduce the CDs to support the center
below and improve the quality and as you
would expect and using poor valves as
opposed to one valve there's an effect
of Pharmacology and that can be seen on
the far right yes it is significantly
quicker and further improvements are
planned in this space Goga have now also
developed an 8 channel head which were
expecting to get holed up in it in the
near turn to fully validate as well and
but all of these things make a big
difference to how food per screen and
what you can do and and in the meantime
as well as looking forward to that 8
channel head we've also been working
with Geiger to develop their software so
allow us to run the four channels in
parallel to make two different liquid
dispenses and classically the only way
to do this would have been to make a
single dispense with all valves and then
move that play physically move it to
another dispenser and were in another
dispense that would take around 50
seconds per dispense and with this new
system with the changes in the software
we can make both additions to the to the
single assay plate in just over a minute
effectively having the time and again
maintaining the quality of signal as you
can see on the right hand side now and
the final piece of innovation around
these dispensers has been actually in
creating smart drains I told you
previously that we have the assistive in
to the laboratory floor so that we can
train waste and excuse me work
effectively at the weekends by running
these systems unattended and now we can
be absolutely sure that the system won't
create waste a solution waste when when
the system isn't connected and this is
simply done with an RF ID tag and
connector so that that signal is only
made when that device is plugged in and
the software within the automation will
only let these and dispensers function
and generate waste when that connections
made really simple innovation but if
it's just high confidence then that we
can learn these systems and attended
over the weekend without any concern of
waste bottles overflowing or waste being
allowed to escape into corporate ring
and finally in terms of the
collaborations and innovation I want to
talk to you about a collaboration that
we've been running with my own field
systems and now I'm field systems have a
device called the plasma knife and this
consists of a centrifugal plate washer a
plasma source a control module and a
series of wash and waste waffles are not
shown in there in the photograph but I
do mention them because they do form and
quite a significant part of this in
terms of the physical size of the tote
total equipment now and working with
assistant detailing place of course
sounds like an excellent idea and
because the potential impact on the cost
of screening or reduction in in plate
use and but also because of the
environmental impact as well if we can
reduce the plastic waste that's
generated and AstraZeneca entered into a
collaboration with I appealed systems in
their beta test program back in 2016 and
and we've done a lot of work with them
over that time period to establish
really excellent cleaning protocols and
reliability of their system and we've
also now been working with n cats who
have a separate collaboration with
unfilled systems
and we're now able to share experiences
and maximize the benefit of this but
simply what we're doing here is taking
our dirty SI plates or used plates and
putting them into the centrifugal washer
and rinses the plates spins them to
remove all of the the waste from them
and washes them with water and ethanol
mix before passing them on to a plasma
knife system and this generates a summer
from high-voltage electronic fields and
this this instantly ionizes any organic
matter that's left on the plates and
vaporizes it so that it's safely removed
from from the surface of the plate and
some of the things that we've worked
with our field systems on actually cover
all of the three pieces of equipment
that we talked about on the first slide
and from the RINs module it's about the
components in there ensuring that a
major hyper hydrophobic material to
reduce the wetness insurability of that
system introducing changes in protocol
to allow pre spin emitting wells before
we start the process adding a solvent
Micro dispense small amount of solvent
to ensure that we've and dissolved
anything which is stuck on that plate
that we don't want before we start and
again and looking at how we can make
this device as green as possible so
shortening rinse times and reducing
waste volumes by doing so for the plasma
module here and through through the
beats test program and the the
controller itself was chained
and that resulted in more focused plasma
being made which was a higher intensity
within the microtiter plates and but
with a lower heat generation so
potentially safer to use within within
the equipment as well and an inclusion
of a rinse step after the plasma
treatment has also been found to be
crucial for the assays and ionization of
the biological material within the
plates could result in ions left within
the plate that affected pH so that wind
steps critical of your assay it can be
affected by the bike pH again we've
worked without a field on generating the
user friendly software and we're
continuing to work with them and now
high res to integrate this software into
our automation setup and the next slide
that I've got here is an example of the
types of things that we saw initially
and this is a a biochemical absorbance a
say it's 1536 well play and and on the
plates we've got dose response curves
and if you look and perhaps in the first
plate top left-hand corner you can see
the the blue colors are running down the
plate and that is a single dose response
curve and then their position in a
snake-like manner all the way around
that plate and and these are these are
compounds that had an inform ecology at
the target that's under test here so
it's not a random screening plate it is
no ecology and what we found initially
when we ran the first protocol that we
had is that when we retested that same
plate in the SA so we've not added any
compound we've just taken that plate and
breelan the SA and that the plate in the
middle is data and from from that and we
could still see some blue coming through
some activity
becoming free from those compounds which
was actually quite a surprise to us and
and again when we look back at those
compounds there was no logical reason as
to why those individual compounds had
carried over they weren't the most
potent there was no specific chemical
structure that led us to believe there
was a reason for it and but we were able
to optimize the protocol and
subsequently clean or starting with the
repeat the original pharmacology play
clean to get complete removal of those
compounds and in this case it was the
introduction of the priests thin and
micro dispense of solvent that allowed
us to remove it and so with an careful
optimization of the protocol were able
to show that this is actually a very
effective way of we use in the
microtiter plates were able to use these
now to produce a new microtiter plate
approximately once every 45 seconds and
within the laboratories here we've
cleaned many different types of plates
and from the polystyrene plates through
two optical plates with glass bottoms
and tested them in several cellular and
biochemical assays so and I hope from
the the examples I've given you there
you can see how we've had several and
successful collaborations working with
vendors to develop infrastructure
develop and systems that are crucial for
long term support - plus screening but
there's something else which is also
important for a - gut screening and the
long term success and that's the service
support model and I'm gonna tell you a
little bit more about how the UK Center
is set up and currently it's in
Manchester and we we have some historic
automation here including the by
ourselves at
you'll six and a high-res a cell robot
alongside the new automation you saw in
the video and which are the high-res
cuca systems with two of those and a
cart the cart system one of those we're
currently looking at expanding the
deployment here to further car to cart
systems as well but this is this is one
part of what will be the UK Centre on
the transition to Cambridge this will
actually become five for high-risk
future systems for cars cart systems and
potentially also an automated chemistry
system DMT a size design make test
analyzed and is how we would describe
our iterative chemistry programs all of
this will be within the UK Center
alongside the ability to run the
automation pack points within a
cleanroom
supported by TC laboratory supported by
compound management and assay
development manual base so we quite a
complicated very very large and
complicated and screening infrastructure
and with that we're anticipating to be
delivering up to 50 screens per year and
that may be as many as 50 million well
screened per year a split across our
open innovation and Astra Zeneca
portfolios we've had to think very
carefully about how we would achieve
this and and how which infrastructure we
would need and that's been modeled based
on the infrastructure I've just shown
you and based on an operation throughout
the day and night during the week and in
order to achieve this demand our
modelling indicates that we would need
to achieve 78 to 80 percent utilization
of those systems and 90% reliability
that reliability of the system is K if
we start a system
90% means if we start a system nine
times out of 10 it will complete without
any user interaction or error okay and
we know that this is a Kiva Bullis and
data here from some of the early bio
cell systems deployed 10 years ago here
with close support on-site engineers and
at the time what was felt to be the
absolute absolutely the best way in
which we could support these systems but
even so we found that we would lose two
to four percent of our data and have to
retest that and that there were many
more errors and that required people to
be around in order and for those plates
to be rescued and encamped and they were
rescue of all and if somebody was there
and in addition to that what we observed
in this data is that many of the the
issues I saw occurred because of human
error and that's the complexity of using
these systems and a lot of what we
talked about in terms of the software is
about reducing the complexity of using
them reducing that human error but
really we also need a an engineering and
a support and group to ensure that the
new systems can reach this level and we
we decided to ask to FISA bias CVRA and
high-res bio solutions to consider how
they would meet these requirements and
key considerations for us were that high
reliability at the future porting of
this this organization from Manchester
to Cambridge and and the complexity of
the third-party devices that were going
to be on these systems and what they
came back with actually was really
interesting they came back and said that
individually neither of them felt that
they were best placed to support this
infrastructure and and so instead they
proposed and that they work together in
a collaboration in order to deliver that
and that's that's different because if
we compare
to what we used to do and that's shown
at the bottom of this slide the standard
they've said model and CPR where are we
a responsible here on site for the whole
website have engineers across science
somebody might be working in how super
screening one day confer management
another and maybe another part of site
on another day and and they're
responsible for that their specs for
trying to resolve issues catalog issues
interaction then with the external
vendors to manage contracts and manage
vendor engineer's coming in as well to
to to resolve issues whereas high res
were were one of those vendors and and a
warranty or under a Support Package when
notified would come in and help resolve
it and what we've been able to do for
the first phase here up some backwards
first phase here in Manchester is is get
an enhanced support model so now we have
a dedicated on-site integrated system
engineer and so they only operates with
us on-site no not on anybody else and is
based within the group so that ease of
interaction and and communication is
much better and we also have an
application specialist as well and and
this helps both with training of our
users but also helps the engineering
side because there's somebody there that
can work with them to ensure that
equipment once it's in fixed is
operating successfully before it's
handed back to our scientists and Harris
is part in this has been that they're
now on site three days a month for
dedicated support beyond their ordinary
support package and they're working very
closely and both with AstraZeneca staff
and with CBRE to train them to ensure
the quality of what we're getting is
it's as good as it possibly can be and
on transition to Cambridge we're
anticipating that the support model from
high res will will increase and we'll
have as well as on-site and CBRE support
will have
on-site high-res personnel for
engineering software and applications
and really driving a close collaboration
between these two groups and typically
the best possible service to to both
Astra Zeneca learning our screens but
also our collaborators that will be
within this space and I want to finish
in the last few minutes of this
presentation to give you an example a
couple of screens that have been run on
our cart cart systems the types of
screens and the reliability that we've
been able to say and the first the
person has actually put screen we ran on
these systems actually on on the cot
cart system was a cell based
gpcrs a using his discover X technology
and this is a technology where we ran
the seeding of the cells into the plates
offline and incubated offline before
transitioning them on to this clinic
platform
once on the platform an agonist was
added and so we're looking for an
antagonist in this case in our screening
approach so we had hitman antagonists
incubated for 90 minutes added our
detection reagent incubated for a
further 90 minutes before leaving on our
multimode reader and so relatively
simple a screening platform or screening
cascade and this this saw between eight
million compounds across a 22 day
screening campaign and move on to the
second screen as well to give you some
details on that and this was a more
complicated cell imaging campaign but
most of the pre work in preparation for
this assay was done offline and was done
manually so they're auditioning bodies
and compounds and washing was all done
offline and there was still a bottleneck
with the ability to read these flights
on the cell inside hence they were
transferred onto the cart to cart
system in order to maximize our use of
those systems and on this in this case
it's a workflow that represent and
storage of our plates in an asterick
store and transfer to storage at room
temperature on the car
reading and then taking back into a
stereo for a long-term storage and what
we found with this assay is that by
doing this we're able to dramatically
increase the number of plates that we
could generate that store so instead of
just having the 48 plates on the car we
can now use the sperry store to store
plates and run a long time into the
weekend and and running to the weekend
without people needing to come in and
reload and the 4° storage followed by an
incubation at room temperature was
critical for this assay because it
improves the signal and by moving it to
room temperature and allows us to only
have it at room temperature for the
period that we need it so there's no
long-term degradation of the sample by
leaving it four degrees and finally by
not having large numbers of plates out
on the platform and because of the way
we're moving them to to and from cold
storage the risk should something go
wrong is also much smaller
and finally the proof of the pudding
here is across these two assays really
low failure rates achieved and what we
found is we've actually completely
eliminated human error on these
platforms which is which is a great
success but for the first HTS the
discover X GPCRs a we did to lose 14 of
1,500 plates and that was a dispensed
area
that's unavoidable sometimes those
things did happen and we did have
occasion where there was a failure in
one of the pieces of software for they
for the plate reader and 50 plates
failed to read and but because of the
nature of the assay we were able to
restart we didn't lose those and that
burg in the software is now being
rectified to that word a teller game and
the second screen here the more complex
self screen again a very low loss rate
due to that improved storage and nine
screening rooms were completed on the
system and many of those out of hours
are over the weekend and we did only
lose one of 500 plates and that was due
to an error on the cell inside again we
believe that we can avoid this in the
future there were two of the separate
automation errors around protists flow
and a2 storage and that did delay the
blade cement they weren't read when they
were supposed to but again due to the
cold storage we were able to reread
those so they weren't actually lost so
the quality of what we've got here in
reduction of rework and elimination of
failure is very very high and one of the
thinnest the presentation actually and
simply by acknowledging and the team
this is a photograph of my team the
height equal screening group at
AstraZeneca
on our one of our away days last year
and a really successful day everybody's
enjoyed themselves there and but
actually really enjoy doing what we do
and working with the vendors
collaborating within and outside of
AstraZeneca to deliver really what is a
high quality infrastructure and and
success the projects and with that I
will finish and take any questions
Thank You Marc for that informative
presentation now and I'll start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen click the send button and
we'll answer as many of your questions
to get time for let's get started
our first question is are there any
limitations on the types of projects
that can be proposed to the open
innovation portal ok thanks and the
there are no limitations on proposals
although the projects that AstraZeneca
would select to advance our projects
that are lined with the the key disease
areas and that's we work in so the
information is is within the book too
long those and they broadly align to
respiratory and information oncology
cardiovascular disease and we have some
interest opportunity to Mystic interest
as well around neuroscience and the the
individual collaborations that we have
with the medical research council are
more open they can bring in any disease
area that they feel is valid for them to
support and the Cancer Research UK
collaborations are limited to the
oncology space great thank you
another question we have here asks how
do you go about starting a collaboration
with a vendor to develop new equipment I
think there's some why it depends on the
type of equipment and and in the
collaborations that I've spoken about
and clearly with the height of of
screening robotics and we looked at the
vendors that were active in that space
and made some
assessment of the equipment that they
had and then we approach them with okay
we like what you've done here but we
would really like to go somewhere else
with it and that conversation at that
point is really interesting most of the
vendors actually of all of the vendors i
propos'd actually are really open to and
those types of conversation and
effectively it helps them with their
product development and so so yeah I I
think it's just a case of approaching
with open question and and really being
clear about the design specification
that you need and the vendors tend to be
open to that okay we have time for one
more question and this one asks do you
think the reliability of systems will
get worse over time so at the new
systems and I think at the moment and
I've shown you some data where there's
been and some issues with books and
software or things that we've been able
to iron out as we've learned about them
I think that's always the way with new
systems and and and I think certainly
shorter might expect that reliability
actually to get a little bit better and
I think the deployment of a service
infrastructure that I've spoken about
and should guarantee that we reached
those really high levels of reliability
and that we maintain them for a really
long time so I guess eventually with any
any system it may well wear out but I
think with what we've put in place we've
got every chance of improving from where
we are and maintaining that for a very
long time I would like to once again
thank mark wiglesworth for his
presentation before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August 2018 you'll receive an
email from laborat setting you know in
this web cam
we'll be available to replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye